look you don't have time and I don't
have time we've got thousands and
thousands of emails yet Gmail the
service most of us use hasn't changed
much about its interface or features in
the last 10 years so let's make a time
trade you give me the next 120 seconds
of your life and I'll give you 10 Gmail
tricks that will save you time in the
long run ready go
number 1 turn on keyboard shortcuts
click the gear icon then settings then
turn on keyboard shortcuts you've now
got the secret key to productivity Pina
number 2 keyboard basics hit C to
compose a new message D to compose in a
new tab and R when you want to reply to
a message got it okay moving on number 3
canned responses stop typing out the
same email message over and over click
the gear icon then settings then labs
scroll to canned responses and click
enable then save now compose a new
message with the text you want to send
click the down arrow in the corner to
save it as a canned response number 4
mute that email chain that has nothing
to do with you by just hitting the M key
number 5 to panes tired of hitting the
back button every time you want to go
from a message back to your inbox setup
preview pane go back to labs and
settings enable preview pane and save
then click here to turn it on number 6
J&K your new BFFs hit the J key to move
forward to the next email in your inbox
hit K to go backwards to go back to your
inbox hit the U key number 7 get shift
done hold down the shift key when you're
in your inbox to select multiple email
threads you may want to delete or
archive hold shift when clicking compose
and it will open in a new window
number 8 better search click the small
down arrow in the search field for
deeper search tools also the search bar
works like regular Google like using
quotes around a specific phrase number 9
quick labels labels can help you
organize your inbox once you've made a
label you can apply it to a message by
dragging it from the
Toolbar number 10 smart responses in the
latest Gmail app for iOS and Android
Google suggests responses based on what
is written in the email above made it
with seconds left on the what are you
still doing here
go get ship done